iPhones are in the news a lot lately
thanks to Apple's ongoing battle with
the FBI in 2014 Apple introduced a
security feature that keeps others
including the federal government from
snooping around your phone but that
security feature could also end up
erasing all your data if say you're too
drunk to remember your passcode or your
kid get to hold up your phone here's
some tips to keep that from happening
first backup your phone the simplest way
to do this is using iTunes it allows you
to choose what content you save and even
gives you the option to encrypt your
data which is great if you have things
you want to keep private
like those late-night dance sessions
yeah let's keep if you're not an iTunes
fan then you can backup your phone over
the cloud the easiest way to do this is
to use a club just go to your settings
to find the iCloud tab you can even set
iCloud to backup automatically if you
backed up with iTunes simply plug in
your phone and fire up the app it should
automatically walk you through how to
erase and restore your backup data if it
doesn't just go to file devices restore
and select the backup you want to use
for those who use iCloud turn on your
phone and follow the instructions you'll
have to sign into Wi-Fi then into iCloud
and pick which backup you want to use
now you'll always have your two-step
safely stored and protected so get down